Speaker 1: All right. This is just funny. Okay.
We're going to have fun now. This is what fun
looks like when the country has been partially
taken over by lunatics. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
had another funny gaffe where she has come out
against hiring based on ethnic anti-Semitic. Now,
you might be saying, well, David, what
do you mean, what's at the dentist? She
clearly means ethnicity, but as usual,
has no idea what she's talking about.
But she's against it, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: You know, private businesses
want to hire based on characteristics and
someone's ability to do the job well. Now,
the Democrats on the left won't want
businesses to have to hire based on skin color
as an intensity or even what gender they identify.
Speaker 1: I would go further. It's not
just that the woke left once ethnic
anti-Semitic based hiring. The left
wants ethnic ness cemented city based hiring.
And that's the first question I ask on my job
applications. When we look to hire people, what is
your ethnic meant percentage city? And of course,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, very well known
for these sorts of gaffes. At one point,
she referred to a petri dish as a peach tree dish.
Speaker 2: You have to accept the fact that the
government totally wants to provide surveillance
on every part of your life. They want to know when
you're eating. They want to know if you're eating
a cheeseburger, which is very bad, because Bill
Gates wants you to eat his fake meat. Right. In a
petri dish picture, you'll probably get a little
zap inside your body and that say, no, no.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So there's Petri dish also,
of course, infamously the gazpacho police.
Speaker 2: Not only do we have the D.C. jail,
which is the D.C. gulag, but now
we have Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho,
police spying on members of Congress,
spying on the legislative work that.
Speaker 1: When she said this, I knew she was a
real bisque, if you know what I mean. And then
this one is not Marjorie Taylor GREENE
But I just it's too good not to include
Lauren Boebert very famously coming out
against one time killings. They made life.
Speaker 2: Hell on earth with their envy, one time
killing. I don't know what a wanton killing is.
Speaker 1: I would have to look that one
up. Yeah, It's like attempted murder by
broad noodle is what I've read it. It
actually works out, too. So, anyway,
these people are clueless. They're clueless
about really important things, but they also just
regularly make up words and they're so confident.
That's maybe the saddest part of the entire thing.